what does a morning look like for you at
the moment if you've got a routine of
some kind yes I run every single morning
I'm up about five five thirty every
morning it starts with the run and
that's because that's the one thing I
hate to do more than anything in the
world I'm all about armoring yourself
the second you leave your house and the
second you open your phone the second
you do any of that you are now letting
in poison in cancer as I get up I start
to armor plate my mind and body you have
to wake up you have to give yourself
belief you have to give yourself
confidence it starts with that run so
after the run I come home I eat
something small how long's the Run
nowhere Under 12 miles and what are you
getting that done in how long anywhere
from about an hour 30 to two hours I run
every day two hours of meditation 90
minutes to two hours of running and I'm
in the gym how long is the gym session
45 to an hour and a half you cycle as
well yeah how long you cycling at least
three or four days a week I'll do that
that's your day there is no room for
anything else yeah there is a lot of
room